حمى الاضرابات تصل الى فرنسا وتهدد
المسافرين خلال عيد الميلاد مئات اننا
رحلات رحلات القطار الغيت بسبب اضراب جديد
للمراقبين لعدم رضاهم رضاهم عن زياده
الرواتب الممنوحه بنسبه 12% على مدى عامين
الغاءه الترت على حوالي 200 الف مسافر
خلال عطلات العيد هذا هو سيتم تسير قطارين
فقط من اصل ثلاثه في عطله نهايه هذا
الاسبوع وابقى تقديرات الشركه الفرنسيه
للسكك الحديديه اضربوا عمال السكك
الحديديه لكن انتقادا حادا من الحكومه
الفرنسيه حيث قال المتحدث باسمها اولوفيفا
ان المظاهرات والمطالب باجور اعلى امر
مشروع لكن لا يوجد تبرير لتنظيم اضرابات
في هذا التوقيت
هذا وتترقب بابريطانيا غدا الجمعه استئناف
الاضرابات بعد توقفها اليوم ما يهدد بخنق
الحياه العامه واصابه البلاد بشلنت حقيقي
فمستوى الاضرابات بلغ خلال شهر ديسمبر
الجاري مستوى قياسيا اذا شهد كل يوم
تقريبا من هذا الشهر وقفات احتجاجيه
وتعطيبا للعمل مطالب برفع الاجور ولا
تنحصر تداعيات الاضرابات في تعطيل حركه
المواطنين ولكنها تسببت في اضرار على قطاع
الصحه والمستشفيات بالاضافه الى التابعات
الاقتصاديه حيث اصدر معهد الشؤون
الاقتصاديه البريطانيه تقريبا يقدر فيه
خساره البلاد بنحو 300 مليون جنيه
استرليني يوميا نتيجه اضرابات شهر ديسمبر
[موسيقى]